how's it going everybody it's warren
welcome back to my channel the cosmic
wonder and we have been getting just
a ton of new marvel news lately it looks
like that time where we weren't getting
really any marvel content because of the
pandemic is officially over as we are
pretty much getting news on the daily
now we have the official one division
trailer we are getting behind the scenes
looks at the falcon and the winter
soldier she-hulk has officially been
cast and yesterday
miss marvel has officially been cast as
well and moon knight is probably right
around the corner
but with yesterday's news that amman
valani has been cast to play kamala khan
aka miss marvel came some other
interesting events
there was an actress who auditioned for
the role of miss marvel who obviously
did not get it because amman got it
but this actress ended up leaking her
script that she got
for the audition online and the story is
actually pretty crazy but
we'll go over the entire thing and we'll
look at the script that was leaked
if you're new be sure to subscribe to
stay up to date on all of the latest
news and
leaks and so you can enter this week's
giveaway for a chance to win a cyclops
funko pop
so i won't mention the name of the
twitter or of the actress because i
don't want her to get any type of hate
for this
and not to mention her twitter account
is now banned because she leaked
confidential information from marvel
studios but this is basically how it
went down
this actress at some point in time that
auditioned for the role of kamala khan
aka ms marvel had mentioned to somebody
either personally or through twitter
that she was in fact
auditioning for the role and could get
the role and it sounds like from the way
some people were responding to her
she actually said that she got the role
of miss marvel but that is just
speculation at this time
however a twitter user that she
seemingly told this information to
tweeted this have y'all ever met someone
that just
lied for no reason in which the actress
replied
okay and then a red heart and then four
pictures of the script and her
nda that she signed now for those of you
who do not know an
nda is a non-disclosure agreement it's
made between her
and marvel and she signed this nda and
what this means is she's not allowed to
tell anybody
anything about her audition for miss
marvel or show them anything
and as you can see here she showed the
script and the nda
and even though she blacked out some of
it that's still violating the nda
but that doesn't really concern us
that's between her and marvel
what we want to talk about is what is on
this script
well some of it is blacked out but
actually a lot of it is pretty readable
so let's go through it so at the very
top it says
this is taking place on a rooftop during
sunset it says jake
and hannah sit on the rooftop
overlooking the city
there's a mini picnic spread out between
them rotus and cups of chai tea
now before we get started it has been
confirmed that hana
is indeed kamala khan it's simply a code
name for the script in case it gets
leaked which
it did but we already know since kamala
khan has been cast that hana is in fact
kamala khan and jake
is most likely red dagger which makes a
ton of sense because
red dagger in the comics is kamala
khan's romantic interest
and in this scene it's taking place on
top of a rooftop
during sunset and there's a picnic
that's pretty romantic
so this scene in the script that we have
is between miss marvel aka kamala khan
and red dagger so here's what it says
red dagger
i bet you can't wait to go back to
jersey and brag about your heroics
miss marvel already tweeted about it red
dagger smiles and then miss marvel
continues
they'd never believe me now here's where
a few lines get a little bit blacked out
but we can pretty much tell what's going
on
red dagger says you can tell people
about and then it gets blacked out and
the last word is
up now it's hard to tell what the
sentence says here but the sentence
underneath that miss marvel says says
yeah
we're like blank the winter soldier
now we can probably assume that she's
saying yeah we're like the falcon
and the winter soldier the falcon and
the winter soldier was
supposed to be the first disney plus
series released but now that's going to
be one division
however it's still definitely coming out
way before miss marvel is going to come
out
which means that the falcon and the
winter soldier could set up some of the
events for miss marvel but as we go on
through the script we find out a little
bit more
red dagger replies with who and then
miss marvel says
are you kidding they're superheroes like
us red dagger then says
you really like to call yourself a
superhero miss marvel because
i am so are you kamala tears a piece of
roadie and munches it delicious red
dagger i'm not
a superhero miss marvel you are kind of
your super power is good hair and being
brave also you're weirdly good at making
roadie
sometimes i think being a superhero is
the only thing i'm good at
in america i'm pakistani in pakistan i'm
american
i feel like a hundred different people
are squished inside of me
and are like hey kamala be like this
where's xiaowar comes
don't wear shower comes eat a mango eat
a cheeseburger you know
red dagger shakes his head no he doesn't
know
ms marvel continues right now the only
person i know how to be
is a superhero red dagger replies you
can be more than one thing kamala
kamala shakes her head no i've tried
i suck at it red dagger replies well
you've got me
miss marvel says you kinda are like my
sidekick in which red dagger replies
me your sidekick i thought you said we
were like
the eagle and the winter soldier in
which miss marvel replies
oh my gosh you are never getting into
the avengers
now i want a real quick touch on this
last line where she says you're never
getting into the avengers
this last line implies that the new
avengers will be a team by the time miss
marvel comes out on disney plus
now we don't exactly know when miss
marvel is going to be coming out
but it's not going to be three or four
years from now over the next one and a
half to two years we're going to be
getting the falcon in the winter soldier
the one division series the loki series
and the hawkeye series
following those are going to be she hulk
and then miss marvel so miss marvel
might come out in 2022 or
2023 that means the new avengers team
will be formed within the next two years
now this last line is sticking true to
kamala khan's comic origin
she is a huge avengers fan in the comics
she was specifically a really big
captain marvel fan who was originally
called miss marvel but when kamala khan
got her powers carol danvers had given
up the name miss marvel and had
started going by the name captain marvel
therefore when kamala got her power she
took on the name
miss marvel after her idol captain
marvel so they're definitely sticking
true to at least a little bit of kamala
khan's comic book origin because she's a
really big avengers fan
in this script and it also looks like
sam aka
falcon and bucky aka the winter soldier
are going to be pretty big moving
forward they're not just going to be
in their own marvel disney plus series
and then we're not going to hear from
them again
they're going to be a huge part of the
mcu and kevin feige the president of
marvel studios has already confirmed
that
all the characters that are appearing in
the disney plus shows will be appearing
in the movies and of course he's also
confirmed that the disney plus marvel
shows
are a part of the mcu so you're going to
have to watch
all of these marvel disney plus shows to
keep up with what's happening in the mcu
and the movies which means we have just
a ton
of different marvel content coming up in
marvel's phase 4
and phase 5. so be sure to subscribe so
you don't miss out on any of the latest
mcu news about phase 4 and
phase 5. now it's pretty cool that we
got this leak script for miss marvel but
it's pretty crazy how we came to get it
regardless it gave us a little bit of an
insight on what we can expect from the
miss marvel series it seems to be a
little bit light-hearted it seems like
it'll probably have some comedy aspects
to it and it seems like it's going to
probably be pretty uplifting
and at this point in time i think we can
all pretty much agree that miss marvel
is definitely going to go on to join
the young avengers all miss marvel wants
to do is go on to become an avenger
unfortunately right now she's too young
she's still just a teenager
but as we can tell from the script she
is fighting crime
so it's only a matter of time until the
young avengers are formed
so let me know what you think about this
leaked script
and let me know what you think about the
casting of kamala khan aka
miss marvel be sure to let me know your
thoughts in the comments down below
don't forget to like the video and
subscribe so you don't miss out on any
of the videos for live updates you can
follow me on instagram and twitter and
as always thank you all so much for
watching
woof